How do you feel about using flaxseed oil if you have a breast tumor?
My carpractor said not to use it because it stimulates estrogen due to three.
Well, it can stimulate estrogen.
There's argument between well-educated professionals about the different oils.
So, you know, some people are on the bandwagon.
All seed oils can increase estrogen, estrogens and cause problems with breast cancer and cause problems with estrogen dominance and whether a cancer or not.
And then there's people on the other side that see seed oils as parent oils and your body converts that to better oils and flaxseed oil is one of the best oils you can use.
And they make really good arguments too.
So my stance is I think the reason why there's studies and highly educated, wonderful health care practitioners on both sides of that aisle is that I think people react to them differently.
So I think maybe the best thing to do in that case then is to test.
So you could do a Dutch test and then start taking flaxseed oil for three months and do another Dutch test and see what it does to your estrogen levels.
I mean, I honestly believe some people react negatively to seed oil.
And they end up with that even if they're all organic and not GMO or anything like that any cross contaminated.
I think it's just the fact that they react negatively to seed oils and some people react very positively to seed oil.
So it's that's a top one. I just interviewed somebody on my podcast.
Can't remember the guys they know about seed oils and he's what he falls on that side of everybody should be taking flaxseed oil.
First of all, when you start saying everybody should be this that let's say it's wrong, you know, everybody should be organic, but it is a little red flag when you go, okay, well, I think everybody's a little different.
That's what I think it is. So you have to be careful that you don't necessarily go down that pathway.
So I think the way to know if you are negatively react to the seed oil, the only way to know is to test.
Because you can't know if your estrogen levels are rising just by how you feel something like that.
Now, you can't have positive reaction. Let's say I want to take flaxseed oil because my skin is dry and this is an issue, this is an issue, and I started taking it. Those things cleared up.
So you could use some, you know, subjective.
If I need as your test, but the objective test that you use is to do a Dutch test to do test performance and see if that negatively affects you from a estrogen number.